thank you
hello everyone welcome to the Lobby
gamespot's weekly hangout here at 2PM
Pacific in San Francisco we have a full
show today we are talking about the
division we're talking about XCOM 2 on
consoles we're going to be taking
Titanfall 2 and Eric Tay and I are going
to debate my destiny rise of iron review
score but first I have a few
housekeeping items
Mary cash and Alexa right Korea as well
as Dan crowd from our Australian office
went to Tokyo for TGs recently and we
have some giveaways namely this
chocolate Crunch that looks kind of like
the Mega Man energy yeah yeah
um got a few other things I'll let
rattle off a few this is Peter Brown by
the way and Aaron Sampson hi
um Street Fighter 2 something what does
this say that's Curry man
okay Curry
um yeah so gamespot's gonna tweet photos
of these uh throughout the day I think
after the show and uh basically just if
you want any of this retweet the photos
for a chance to win them here's
kingsglaive Final Fantasy stuff
Pete can you uh
can I there's a few more things in there
but yeah just pay attention to the game
spots Twitter feed and we will get those
to People based on who retweets and
whatnot we also have a Forza Horizon 3
stream by Rob Hamley right after the
show yeah cool let's get into it make it
through customs I have no idea that's my
question that's a sword or something
anyway all right we're gonna talk about
the division for a specific reason not
just because we have nothing else to
talk about there's a new update in the
near future update 1.4 which I'll let
you describe a little more but basically
it's a lot of like quality of life
changes but right now it's in public
test servers for uh on Uplay not steam
yet uh Ubisoft said it would be on Steam
soon enough I don't know it's on in
their words but so tell me is this like
what's up with the update why would this
bring people back why are we talking
about the division again yeah I think
the big thing in the division right now
is is so they they delayed their DLC
um survival and Last Stand and they're
trying to get the core game hook as good
as they can a lot of things they've done
or they're testing right now or quality
of life improvements on the shooting
side they're trying to lower time to
kill they're trying to drop loot that's
more relevant to your level and sort of
do that Destiny thing where you slowly
grind your way up at a pace
um they're like increasing ammo like I
think a lot of what they're trying to
get away from on the shooting side is
just where you you literally run out of
ammo trying to kill somebody
um which is just kind of a boring way to
play a shooter yeah but I mean it seemed
very much like Destiny when I first
played it uh in the fact that it was
kind of more of an MMO to me because the
shooting mechanics the third person
mechanics felt good but it was more of a
like bullet sponge enemies and like loot
gear and whatnot but I don't know I I
was wondering how much more they would
need to do for this to actually become
like people are someone had said it's
kind of like the taken Kingdom like you
had said the way you're kind of just
grinding for like levels now instead of
going for these specific exotic items
Etc yeah and
you know I think
like if you're gonna have
gonna have it or you have to start with
the best shooting shooting right or else
you don't have anything which Destiny
has really good mechanics the reason
that Destiny I think the reason that
people stuck with Destiny for so long as
a as a like year-long beta test up until
taken King was that the Core Shooting
was so good that it was worth sticking
around to see what happened with the
loot system because like Destiny was a
game where you got to a boss after a
long game and you shot them and nothing
came out right it was just totally
busted loot system division it was like
a very similar feel you just didn't feel
like you were gaining much of anything
as you played if you played the game
kind of casually as it was meant to be
played if you were willing to get into
the whole resource grind like you know
someone like Eric Tay did then you could
probably get what you were looking out
of it um that sense of satisfaction but
I don't know for a guy like me I'm a
shooter fan I was looking for good
shooting mechanics
and time to kill was a big issue the
other big issue which they have not
addressed in this patch yet or they've
not addressed in the public test is just
enemy lack of enemy reaction right so if
enemies run at you with high-powered
weapons it's a cover-based shooter and
you are the only one who has to take
cover
and if they're running straight at you
and they don't stagger or have fear or
do much of anything except for a couple
of weapons like the lmg where they'll
suppress
then like what do you have you don't
really have a cover-based shooter right
you just have a game where people charge
at you and kill you at point-blank range
yeah like the few hours I did play uh it
was infuriating that people with
baseball bats could run up to me and I
could put 10 bullets in them and they'd
still be alive one hit from that
baseball bat would kill me yeah
what it's a very very off-topic tangent
but I remember that's one reason like
one of the reasons I didn't like
Resident Evil 6 because like for the
first time in the series when you shoot
zombies they're not reacting yeah and I
didn't feel like there's any impact and
I want to in a shooter I want to feel
that impact like Destiny you get the
headshots a lot of times her head
explodes like you get they drop an item
uh you know you kind of when you knife
them they go flying it makes sense it
feels like you're actually affecting the
enemies in the game world and I remember
that too because I just I was watching
the health bar not the enemy as I was
just unloading magazine after magazine
into them and I guess my question is
what this pushed the DLC back like you
were saying uh survival the next plan
one is like later this year at some
point and uh Last Stand is next year now
2017. uh do you think this update will
be worth getting into or do you think
people are still better off waiting for
the DLC I think what's going to bring
people back is the DLC and I'm guessing
that their intention is that they'll
retain those people with better quality
of life so
um they're also making other things
easier in this game so in addition to
new content that they made it may or may
not be good I don't know like that's
still up to them
um they're doing small things like you
know weapon skins used to take up all
your inventory space so if you wanted
cool skins for your weapons you have to
give up like tangible items in the game
um they didn't have basic stuff like
bulk conversion at crafting stations
that they're trying to get in now so you
would spend like tons of time pressing
each one to break it down
um the big one that that is a big deal
for me is locking items which is
something that's been in Destiny for a
while but you could very easily have
accidentally deleted a lot of your high
level gear in this game if you've marked
a bunch of stuff to delete it to break
it down but you were accidentally
clicked on your gun that you were using
which is common and you hit delete
whatever you marked it would also delete
your main gun and it didn't tell you
that that was equipped or that was your
best gun there wasn't like a warning hey
you're about to delete your favorite
whatever so like these quality of life
improvements
give the game the potential that if the
next DLC has enough content
that people will stick around after that
and continue the the leveling grind and
they might enjoy the lower time to kill
and like just the general shooting
better so it's it's an opportunity for
them that being said I don't know their
first DLC just should have been called a
room like DLC of the room because that's
all it was their incursion was just
like a place you walk into you saw the
boss right away it was just standing
there yeah and the only thing that that
Mo did was flush you out of cover and a
cover based shooter continuously until
you killed the thing at the other end of
the room and it just wasn't wasn't
compelling so in terms of the actual
progression this seems like like you had
mentioned it might be more like we're
gonna talk about rise of iron later it
seems like it's more of a gradual grind
kind of in terms of progression and like
you said not someone that's Min maxing
and actually knowing exactly what item
to get and how to kind of maximize that
item's capabilities now it's more of it
if you want to play casually a lot you
you will build your character yeah Goku
Bola King once a day you can go do the
new underground DLC which I think is
probably the best way to get loot
um for casual players again like you
just go through it you get great loot
every day
um
the dark Zone I think is still kind of a
mess like I don't know why I would play
the dark Zone as opposed to underground
DLC because I'm guaranteed loot in the
underground whereas the dark Zone you
work really hard and then somebody just
kind of shoots you in the back yeah and
then they even patch it so like even if
you get your stuff on the line you get
away they can still just come back and
cut the line take your stuff but it's
hard to tell um they started everybody
off in the public test server with a
base character it was a bass leveled
character so nobody's gotten their new
vector or whatever yet so we still can't
tell maybe the dark zone is still pretty
busted won't be able to know for a
couple weeks until people get the new
stuff again yeah I mean I only played a
few hours of this game and the reason I
liked it and I think the reason it was
initially appealing to me before it
released was just the game World this
decrepit in New York City that you know
like you had spent a lot of time when
you're younger not at the crap in New
York City but New York City no decrepit
New York City yeah you hung out in the
slums and as you would but no we uh I
that's I think this is what I've been
waiting for the DLC was never
interesting to me some like big revamp
that would actually make the game fun to
me yeah was what I was waiting for so
I'm wondering
it doesn't sound like this is enough but
maybe I'll still try go back and play an
hour and see if it's like gripping me
but I mean we have a lot of games coming
out but the division result is the one
this year that I feel like I didn't give
a chance I don't know are you interested
in going back at all yes no I mean
because I did try to give it a chance I
spent like maybe three to four hours
with the game and sort of the problems I
described earlier were the things that
turned me off but yes the world is
interesting I like the concept of people
sort of like meeting this Camp to like
go out on these missions and like that's
all great
um so yeah like if the the sort of like
small moment-to-moment stuff is improved
and streamlined and made just to feel
more fun uh I I could see wanting to
play it again but it for me it's almost
like that time has passed
which sucks because there are so many
good games that are just good no matter
when you try to play them
um but yeah the division I mean I I feel
like I'd have to start over at this
point so I would have to do a lot to get
me to start over it's interesting
because I mean you mentioned starting
over I think when taking King came out a
lot of us were jealous of people who
maybe never played Destiny before yeah
because they were getting The Full
Experience they were getting the
originally the most the most of what the
original design was for that game yeah
and that's how I understood the division
I thought Ubisoft was making more of a
platform kind of to maybe like once a
year like destiny released this
expansion or like that's actually going
to revamp things and kind of change how
you think the game works and how the
game works and like not the mechanics
but the actual systems at play and I
think that's what I'm waiting for for
the division and this doesn't seem
substantial enough I mean it's only in
public test servers right now but it
doesn't seem substantial enough for me
to jump back in especially like with
other games on the horizon but I don't
know I kind of like the DLC just doesn't
appeal to me because again that's just
the same game with more content
especially judging by the room it
doesn't sound like there's much promise
there and also the public test servers
aren't always necessarily for that game
the Battlefield 4 pelvic test server
realistically was to make the next
Battlefield game better and division did
sell extremely well and this may be for
them to fix everything for the next
division game I mean I don't know they
could walk at this point and I think it
would still be a success at least
financially for their company and they
could make a better sequel if they
wanted to learning from the public test
in the meantime
yeah well that is the update 1.4 public
test servers the update is not
officially out yet that is available on
Uplay and it will be on Steam at some
point Ubisoft has not said when yet but
they said it will be soon so go check
that out and let us think let us know
what you think in the comments below
let us think about let us think more
about this game all right Aaron thanks
for coming on I appreciate your division
expertise we're gonna bring Scott
Butterworth on a second Pete how's uh
how are things going this week with you
he's gonna be going better man yeah no
things are good you looked concerned
before this one I'm concerned there's a
lot going on today like a lot of it's
very interesting uh it's kind of
compounded by the fact that next week
I'm taking off and uh gone for a couple
weeks it's Outback just going to the
Outback getting a lot of steak and
blooming onions yeah you're going to
China in Japan right yeah nice yeah I've
never been
they sound cool though they are cool
Scott Butterworth what's up he's right
they're very cool they're way cooler
than being here in the office yeah I'm
very jealous but uh it's nice being here
on this on the lobby set this is nice
yeah got the nice mood lighting we have
the SS Pikmin to enjoy so you know
that's good talking about Titanfall 2
Titanfall 2. uh you recently went down I
think did you go down to uh their Studio
respawn cool yeah and uh you got to
pretty much see you saw some single
player which we can't talk about I don't
think correct yeah I actually got to
play a pretty substantial portion of
like the complete campaign but yeah that
is still embargo until a little later
this week so check back on I don't know
if I'm allowed to say the Embargo but
yeah later this week we'll say maybe
around Thursday just keep refreshing The
Game Spot home page never run over yeah
yeah just for the rest of yours just
exactly just have your phone at all
times just walk and refresh so so we uh
so Rob and I have gone to play uh a lot
of it too we did a preview series on it
kind of like two-part series on how this
is kind of like they're trying to
correct mistakes they may with the first
Titanfall but also like how this is
becoming almost like a hero shooter in
my view of how like the Titans are
designed and how it becomes like you can
see a Titan signature moves and you can
see you know like how to counteract them
and they can see yours it's kind of like
a chess match almost at that point but
you got to see all six Titans finally
yeah yeah and actually got to play all
six as well um so it wasn't just like
here's a trailer because they put
trailers up a couple weeks ago to kind
of vaguely introduce what each of the
new Titans does but yeah so the
multiplayer you have choice of any of
the six Titans um and and yeah I mean I
wouldn't necessarily call it like a hero
shooter more maybe like a class space
shooter because each of the Titans does
seem to kind of represent a different
class in a way
um at least if you go judge them
according to like their Primary Weapons
like for example Ronan has a shotgun and
a sword like those are his Primary
Weapons so he's clearly like the up
close damage dealer he's that kind of
tank type right phase shift too right
that can go behind phase shift is really
cool um yeah like so Pilots have a cloak
ability but this is not that this is a
different thing basically like you just
blink out of existence entirely like you
don't even have a shadow that people can
track like you're just simply not there
so you can't be damaged you can't be
seen it only lasts a few seconds though
and when you're in that state uh you
actually can't see your opponents you
just see like a black and white kind of
version of the world and can maneuver so
it's useful for a couple of reasons like
my my favorite was to just charge
straight at people and as soon as they
kind of like got me in their sight I
would blink out of existence and
continue to rush at them in like the
parallel Dimension and then when I
snapped back into reality I was suddenly
like right in their face with a sword
and shotgun exactly so that was really
fun and really awesome but then in
contrast to someone like Northstar who I
think Rob's a big fan of and that
character like that character's base
weapon is essentially a sniper rifle
like the exact opposite where you want
to play the spacing game you want to
hang back and and not only is it it's a
railgun so it charges up over time so
you really can't be in people's face
with that character you have to hang
back you have to bide your time
um so yeah in my mind it is kind of
class based you have a tank you have a
sniper you have this shotgun running
Gunner like all these different types
and and play Styles so so whatever
you're into there's probably a Titan
that'll Loosely fit what you want to get
out of the game yeah and then like
Northstar just to backtrack quickly is
that the one that has a kind of pharah
Justice from above Reigns from above
yeah totally yeah as you mentioned so
each of the Titans has sort of an ultra
ability and like once so over the course
of a round as you like accumulate damage
and do other things to contribute to
your team you eventually unlock their
ultra
um and yeah so in northstar's case it's
essentially like a pharah death from
above like VTOL hover plus like homing
missile barrage that's pretty uh
inspiring is it referred to as an ultra
I don't honestly like I'm trying to
remember
um so each Titan has a core like ability
they're described as like he's the sword
core let's let's stop latching onto new
terms this is a class-based thing like
you said which I'm happy about this is
not hero no this is a class
these are it's an ALT this dude okay if
you can open reference
out of your chest and shoot a laser out
of it what would you that's not that's
not ultimate I would call
I don't know so when mobas were invented
then weekends no um
I believe they're called core abilities
that's just not yeah as
so nobody knows what that means outside
of this context though like if we sit
and explain to a question call it a
super okay just sounds like they have
really nice Titan has a super
yeah they they all sit on those stupid
balls all day and it really works their
midsection and they'll yeah really
taught abs look for the hot calendar
coming out next year cool uh real sexy
do you have like a favorite Titan
because you said there was one that's
kind of like just to piss Pete off I'm
gonna use another OverWatch you did say
there's like a soldier 76 and like Call
of Duty like kind of every man character
uh Titan that like anybody that's played
a shooter will get yeah so um one of the
Titans I'm trying to remember if it's a
legion or tone I believe it's Legion has
a sort of minigun and a really good
all-around mix of like Health damage and
speed so they that that particular
character is you know just sort of
well-balanced equally uh I mean it's
just doesn't serve as deep a niche
purpose as somebody like Northstar who
really has to hang back or someone like
Ronan who really has to be up close to
be effective
um the minigun is like has an up close
uh switch or like you can change its
firing mode sorry to backtrack you can
change its firing mode so you can fire
either like a steady stream of bullets
or a wider spray so he's useful from a
variety of different ranges he again has
a strong movement and health so you can
kind of play him as more of the standard
mid-range shooter character it'll be a
good I think intro for people because
everybody immediately understands how a
minigun works right like it charges up
you fire a bunch of bullets things in
front you die even that character's
super uh is like an amped version it's
really nothing too different like you
just fire slightly more powerful bullets
so it's not like oh you take off in a
raining bullets or oh you phase shift
out of existence it's oh your bullets
are just more powerful so again really
easy to understand really like low
barrier to entry for that particular
character but still totally fun to play
because again who doesn't love a minigun
and just like completely shredding
everything in the environment yeah um
Ronan unfortunately has very limited
health though so uh I would generally
like get up close take down one Titan
and then be it basically at the point of
death but you can still equip a nuclear
eject which people may remember from the
previous game so it's pronounced nuclear
nuclear eject I'm pretty sure it's the
uh so the foliage in the library
um
where was I going with this uh this has
been really like derailment heavy
episode today
um what the hell was I talking about
just the overall phone oh yeah you can
blow up you blow up and take people down
with you it's awesome so it doesn't
matter you have very little health
because as soon as you die you explode
and everything around you in Center oh
cool Okay Okay cool so how does it feel
overall these feel balanced is the flow
of the multiplayer still feel intact
with six people instead of just the two
we've seen so far yeah well actually so
um to me it feels way more complete and
way more interesting than the beta did
the beta obviously was missing a lot of
content I mean you only had two two of
the six Titans but also there were a
bunch of missing maps and a bunch of
Missing pilot abilities so I wanted to
talk about that as well because the game
is more than just Titans obviously
um and I know a lot of people um that
I've spoken to about the beta came away
thinking like oh man why would you ever
play with anything but the grappling
hook the grappling hook kind of changes
the game completely for Pilots it's you
know suddenly wall running or free
running is no longer as as essential as
it was but on some of the new maps I
found that the grappling hook wasn't
even that useful in a way like there's a
really dense new map called Eden where I
found that it was dense enough there
were enough objects to sort of wall jump
off of that I was able to make my way
through the city and keep my momentum up
without ever relying on the grappling
hook which meant that I could use that
skill slot on something else and there
are other abilities that are actually
like appealing and useful some more than
others I was I was sticking to that like
sonar pulse knife maybe that just comes
from like my background and just
Shooters in general like knowing where
people are is obviously a huge deal yeah
and I think I'm just more comfortable
with that and like I could rely on the
really fine-tuned wall traversal and
like wall runs and like vaults and I
didn't have to worry about the grappling
hook where's the knife I could just
throw stand still see if anybody's above
me below me around me or just on the Run
just see if anybody's about to Ambush me
I don't know I I didn't think the
grappling hook was as huge of a deal as
a lot of people did it's cool it's fun
but and I feel I think it feels great
but I wasn't like one of those people
that was you know kind of you know like
you said being attached to it yeah I'm
actually cutting with you attached to it
grapple that's good um yeah there are
certain Maps where it makes a lot of
sense Peter shaking said I don't know if
he was on camera right there but that's
that's the correct reaction Peter
um yeah there are certain Maps where it
makes a lot of sense because uh the maps
now I I would argue have more
verticality than the maps did in the
first game so
um if you are down like deep in a trench
and you're trying to get to the top of a
building and there's like a large uh
scalable section you may not be able to
wall jump your way up that but the
grappling hook can save you much time
boom hey use can suddenly Traverse a
section of the level that other Pilots
can't yeah very useful but not every map
has that
um so that like I said there are plenty
of situations where the grappling hook
is going to be less useful than other
skills sure so I think once people get a
chance to play all of the content
together and see how it all fits
together uh and see how all the
different tactics complement one another
they'll realize that it's a bit more of
a complete product than the beta was and
I don't know that it made I'm not
guaranteeing that everybody who hated
the beta is actually gonna love the full
game people might still hate it but I I
personally enjoyed what I was able to
play last last week much more than I
enjoyed the beta in large part because
there's so much more going on and
there's so much more strategy and if you
see the other team is using certain
types of Titans you can pick a Titan to
give yourself an advantage over that
type because you can switch between
deaths and just that ability to switch
on the Fly and adjust your tactics and
change all this stuff and having all
these options really makes the game kind
of more rich but all the essential stuff
is there there's still Mech battles
there's still wall running and you know
all that kind of stuff it's still
Titanfall to me even if certain things
have changed but yeah I mean I had a lot
of fun with it I really enjoyed my time
cool so you got your full like preview
stuff up on Gamespot your single player
stuff is coming later this week and
we'll be able to talk more about how the
Titans work there and how the story is
unfolding and whatnot full profile on
all the Titans went up last week people
should definitely go check that out Rob
Handler did an amazing job editing
together a video conversation that we
had and yeah single player stuff going
up later this week Rob's in the room
that's why I insulted him cool hey there
he is
so that's Titanfall 2 uh like Scott said
he's got his content up on the site
right now uh we have single player stuff
coming later this week and that releases
October 28th for or PS4 or Xbox One and
uh we can see how it like the beta was
indicative of the game then NPC NPC
sorry I forgot that one thanks I know
that people would yell at you if you
didn't say that it definitely would cool
I've got your back man I appreciate it
Scott thanks for talking we're gonna
have Rob come on bye guys
I'm excited for Titanfall too it's fun
are you excited for the next time I want
to derail this conversation I dare you
go ahead and try it no I will okay I can
and I will all right whatever Rob Henley
what's up uh not a whole lot just got my
little notes here for the next segment
the next segment a game you haven't
really played
what are we talking about first XCOM 2
yeah
cool have you played next time too uh no
not really well I brought you on to a
lot of questions of me because I played
a lot of cool anyway cool so that's the
intro we're talking about XCOM 2. I've
played a lot of it it's on consoles as
of today PS4 Xbox One uh released back
in February I think it was 27th 17th
there's a seven somewhere in there
yeah correct yeah I'm not gonna screw
that up you're trying to derail this
already no it's a very good game I liked
it a lot I gave it a nine uh one of my
like my favorite strategy games I've
ever played in terms of being a sequel I
think it's everything I wanted it took
the familiarity from XCOM Enemy Unknown
and just kind of made the strategy layer
of Base building and like traveling
around the map and Resource Management
deeper and made the tactics kind of even
more varied with this many more like
options and Nuance to it
um like the storyline was just there to
facilitate the action but it was just
all around like a challenging game that
I loved playing every second of I know
you guys have not spent much time with
it but I just want we just it's not in
console we want to talk about whether
it's worth returning to on consoles for
people who played it or it's worth just
playing if you have not played it yet
well I don't know Mike I'm gonna chill
the hell out of this game because I know
a lot of people in our office haven't
like gotten the chance to play it yet
yeah um which is unfortunate I think
it's just because again it just released
on PC and the Enemy Unknown was just on
consoles right away
um and I wish that wasn't the case but
now I'm hoping the console release will
get this game to more people's hands
because it's a very good game
um do you guys have any interest in
trying it now that it's on console
um well my first question is is like how
you know for a x-com game and many other
like just like strategy games you want
that like fluid Mouse work like that's
very important I feel like for clicking
for such a heavy HUD how does that work
is I mean is it is it a cursor I mean I
would imagine it's it's you snap around
right you yeah you move like the analog
stick moves it through the tiles and
then the line of like where the soldier
will move based on where you put it so
if you put it here it's going to show
the line going around this crate and
around this one it's definitely not as
fluid it's just a mouse but it like to
be on consoles it feels very good you
know you can kind of uh they're like hot
buttons you press to go into OverWatch
uh you know like to guard your teammates
there are certain buttons to use
different abilities the the button
mappings feel really natural
um the keyboard obviously the same thing
you could work those out just as easily
but like mouse cursor the more you play
with the analog sticks the less you kind
of notice uh it's not the ideal way to
play it but it looks just as good as on
PS4 Xbox One from what I noticed uh
there you go you can see how it's
wrapping around objects and you know
like you get 2 turns most characters
unless they have special abilities and
everything but it feels really good it's
fast it's not it doesn't feel cumbersome
when you're trying to like plan out your
moves uh but it it has made the
transition well in terms of the
interface from in my experience what's
the deal what's your hunch why did this
take so long I don't know they they
delayed it what was it like last earlier
this month or last month they were
originally going to release it yeah but
I mean even just then like months
removed from the PC version when enemy
unknowns oh right because they've been
talking for like a year before it
released on PC that it's like it's
developed it's developed for PC and a
lot of people thought that meant it's
only coming to PC but then like you
start looking at it they're like no it's
just saying they developed it from the
ground up for PC they never said they
weren't gonna like Port it or whatever
bring it over to consoles I don't know
you're like The Tech Guy why would it be
would that could attack play into that
at all I I don't know what tools they're
using to make these games but I mean the
architecture on the new consoles is very
similar to what most people and most
developers develop for on PC yeah so I
guess that's why I'm slightly confused
um why it took so long and I kind of
feel bad that it took so long because in
the slew of new releases this might
actually get lost and it does sound like
such a great game
um I mean you loving like Final Fantasy
Tactics they're very different games but
I keep telling you like in terms of like
the combat and the taxes I think you'd
love this game I think I would too and I
think it coming to console will make it
easier for me to play just because it's
PC gaming at home just isn't as simple
for me as it is in the office and when
I'm here a lot of other stuff going on
so
I want to play it like yeah well I mean
what are the things people should know
because yes it's a nine but but what
sort of problems does the game maybe
have not to paint it in a negative light
but but yeah like what's the full story
some technical issues have like migrated
from PC that were there I haven't played
PC in a while I don't know if they're
still present uh a lot of times you'll
start a turn and then you'll like
initiate an attack it'll zoom in into
the action camera and you'll hear the
action going on but the character will
be frozen in place for like sometimes up
to 10 seconds and it's nothing game
breaking but every once in a while it
tests your patience uh a lot of
sometimes like enemies will be able to
shoot through walls they should not be
able to shoot through and like I've
known this game well enough to know that
they don't have this upgrade or they
don't that alien can't do that
um that happens every once in a while so
that was one of my initial complaints on
PC is every once in a while like not
enough to hinder the overall experience
but sometimes the enemies will ignore
the rules that you have to abide by
which like the odds are stacked against
you in this game that's the whole point
you're rising up against this like
overpowered alien occupation Force and
you're like this squad of Rebel Fighters
but in general none of these technical
issues impacted the game on PC from back
in the day again I don't know if they
have addressed them but even on Console
like I experienced a few of them in the
few hours I played just to double check
that consoles work well yeah
um but yeah they I in terms of maybe
that was a problem they had bring into
consoles if they did like fully Port it
maybe they had more a month ago that
they had to kind of fix sure I have no
idea is there any incentive for someone
on PC who is a huge fan of XCOM to come
back to a console so that's like you
know they have an audience
it just seems like I missed I think
Peter kind of said it like on this
opportunity to like have these come out
more succinct or like more you know in a
similar deadline if you if you just want
an excuse if you like have like if you
have it on PC no there's not much reason
because it comes with a DLC which PC
obviously already has PC also has mods
which I was showing you I got like Star
Wars mods you can make the guys look
like Boba Fett you can get the Halo guns
which actually have different stats
they're not just skins
um like that's why DLC kind of became a
little less relevant with this big game
because the mod support was out from the
beginning so people could make really
cool stuff but like alien hunters uh
Anarchy's children and there's one more
that I'm forgetting uh are present on
the console release so if you've already
played it on PC if you already own it
not much incentive to come back unless
you're like me and just like need an
excuse to play it again for a little bit
uh if you don't have it on PC and you're
like if you're a console player
obviously go buy this game it's well
worth the 60 of the full packages with
the DLC and everything and I highly
encourage it when did the last DLC come
out because it sounds like that might be
the thing that they were just taken care
of before uh if it was I think it was
alien hunters then Anarchy's children uh
and then there might be one more more
but it was about two months ago I think
and that was the one where uh it was
kind of uh like
that you've made them look like Mad Max
characters kind of it was like character
customization stuff
um but it was maybe that was what they
were to land for to make sure they got
all the DLCs but but that could be yeah
I mean that's how a lot of development
Studios work and I like Bethesda when
they're working on from what I
understand Bethesda a lot of times
they'll have they'll keep their like
Fallout 3 team on until the DLC is done
and then migrate them over Fallout 4
team until dlc's done then bring them
over to you know whatever game they're
working on next I don't know I don't
want to sound like I do but yeah I have
no idea it is kind of a shame that it's
coming out right now when like you have
I don't know gears fours on the way FIFA
just came out those crowds don't really
overlap but then you have Battlefield 1
Titanfall 2 Call of Duty Dishonored two
Watch Dogs 2 Watchdogs two Mafia three
is Mafia three is the next big one I
think yep yeah I think we're doing like
a section on the next episode or an
episode down there like our favorite
holiday sieve too right Civ sixth uh
same day as uh Battlefield 1 October
21st
yeah those are different audiences
though yeah still though it's a slew of
games yeah totally yeah so XCOM 2 is on
Console now PS4 Xbox One it was on PC
back in February but if you haven't
played it on PC and if you want to get
like the whole package with uh all the
DLCs I highly recommend it go check out
our review on Gamespot gave it a 9 out
of 10.
that is XCOM 2. guys go play it don't be
a dummy play some XCOM yeah for your
health for your health go to it all
right
speaking of Battlefield 1.
rob you just watched a story trailer I
watch a story trailer P watch the story
trailer I think we have differing
opinions oh really from my what I don't
know Pete sits near me and I heard his
reaction oh of course like it was
curmudgeon like oh a six-story trailer
[Music]
what did you think of it I was into it
you liked it um I was into it because
geez where to start I don't know I was
into it because we've seen the gameplay
for the most part I think we all know
what this game's this game's gonna look
pretty good based just based on the beta
alone I feel like
um and I was interested where they were
gonna take this depressing ass War
uh and how they're gonna present it and
inject like I mean you know it wasn't
like a you know
huge explanation of the plot or anything
but you saw a lot of these conflicting
moments with like do I shoot do I not
kill you do I do you know and and I
think that's the the Battle of
um you know people's opinions of the war
in general like why were we fighting
um and that seems to be apparent in this
it's also like dice's challenge how do
you depict one of the bloodiest
conflicts ever yeah yeah but there's
there's a there's the other side of the
coin where yes there is that people the
thing where people are like oh man this
war what are we doing but the other hand
there's a guy like we will go into
battle and if one out of every thousand
of us has remembered imagine the war
stories that will be told for ages to
come
I have very conflicting emotions because
the first half seems like they're going
from a more personal level and maybe how
it's going to affect them and then
there's a there's a part in the Middle
where the music dies down and it starts
getting Grim I'm like oh this is awesome
like it's these people coming into war
like everybody's romanticizing it
they're like we're gonna like storm No
Man's Land we're gonna get across and
then I thought it was gonna cut back to
like the grisly aspects of it the [__]
that like you don't want to see that I
was hoping guys would put in but then it
just cut right back to that like that
speech you're just telling but it's like
uh if we fight like if we push we can
win or something like a locker room
speech before a World War one battle
Yeah like the game looks great it looks
better in this trailer than it does in
motion and that's saying a lot because
in motion it looks fantastic but in
terms of the story I'm getting from it I
just don't feel like I'm getting there's
enough for me to really feel confident
about it because these are these are
such small Snippets that they're
providing us sure I do like that this
trailer like I don't know if it's that
they're actually gonna follow through
but the trailer kind of hints at a
character-driven campaign which like in
the past Battlefield pretty much spent
like that Macho military Wonder jargon
stuff one dude versus all so this one is
what there's you said there's five
characters There is five perspectives of
the war and I was actually hoping for
um aside a perspective from the central
power side may it be German or um but
this apparently is all Allied so uh
having like broken some sound the
battlefield uh put this on their site so
I kind of skimmed through it so like the
two British Pilots That's your one
perspective that's more or less a
chapter of this single player campaign
you have your tank crew which having
read it it
it seems to be almost the exact same
idea of the movie Fury I was gonna say
it's like Yeah from the beginning from
the first trailer from E3 I was I had a
Vibe of that you know being stranded in
a tank with your Treads out with Shia
LaBeouf straight up it's very much that
in that they talk about in a very brief
uh uh moment they said like uh with the
character that you are playing or seeing
is a newbie who is being introduced to
this rugged unprofessional tank crew
et cetera et cetera Etc uh and and he's
trying to basically you know build a
team you have different you know you
have the Bromance and the planes
basically these two guys like don't will
you take me back home like I'll do my
best I will hold you yeah
shirtless volleyball scene yeah yeah
very much so uh and then it goes as far
to Italian
um perspective in the Alps uh farewell
to arms-ish kind of place it seemed to
be the moments of when the guy's putting
on that heavy armor it's like a they're
calling like a mountaineer regimen
called our DD I guess is like the
Italian Force that's like a almost like
comparison to shock troopers from like
um World War II maybe that's where like
flamethrowers come into players I think
so that's where you'll see a lot of that
action and then um the last being uh and
then probably one of the most depressing
moments in the war is um
Gallipoli yeah yeah and so you you
participate in that as the Australian
Runners so you are running info from
probably trenches trench yeah a lot of
chaos and you get Snips of those I
believe kind of look like Landing crafts
um you know storming that um Ottoman
Empire that was the entire focus of the
movie Gallipoli with uh like Mel Gibson
it was on like carriers and like how
like just to get from trench to trench
and whatnot and uh yeah it was like the
failed attempt for the uh Australians to
kind of
end the war early at least on the
ottoman front so that's interesting
wasn't there a Bedouin woman they kept
showing and mentioning yes that's the
other one uh and I didn't know this that
is very much they're they're saying that
she is like Lawrence of Arabia's
right-hand woman yeah or man whatever
you want to call that phrase but yeah
she's there like the whole step away
um and they're basically against the
Ottoman Empire has you see a lot of
these that's where the train um
behemoths come in with the heavy
artillery I guess they're they're trying
to make a push on that and obviously
that's in like the desert setting yeah
horseback just like that it seems like
not just like in terms of the characters
but in terms of their archetypes it's
kind of dividing the character classes
up by campaigns you said there's the guy
in the Italian Alps who's kind of more
of the assault uh you sounds like The
gallivoli Messengers are more of the
Scout classes almost it sounds like
they're a lot more stealth probably a
little bit Behind Enemy Lines sure yeah
and then there's the Harlem hellfighter
did you already mention that I don't
know about much about that but what I do
know is so that's five chapters more or
less with missions being in those and
then there's a unnamed kind of epilogue
which has only a handful of missions so
I wonder if that's gonna
tie in any or any other loose threads to
the story of the campaign and then yeah
they showed the last shot of the trailer
of the Harlem hellfighter against like a
German soldier kind of standoff yeah
both hesitating to pull the trigger and
whatnot but a lot of people I think said
when they heard they're making this game
they're like would that be awesome if
the server shut down on Christmas for
the Christmas Truce it wouldn't happen
but that'd be really cool but the Harlem
Hell fighter I remember when they first
announced like the collector's edition
they said something about the Harlem
Hell Fighters was part of a DLC yeah
sure well they wouldn't they wouldn't
put an epilogue in DLC would they no but
they could put the epilogue to tease
something for DLC right there's been
leaks or something like cracked open
like the beta itself and found that
there was like a patch that said like
French patch or I don't even know if uh
dice or anyone has even said that there
will be like a French DLC
um down the road huh I mean I I know
they said they're trying to go to like
on like unexplored territory for World
War One in terms of like in like media
and entertainment but I feel like
they've got San Quin Scar the
multiplayer which is already in France
like France is like where some of the
bloodiest battles took place as like a a
team to play on us play us oh gotcha so
like an actual like side okay that'd be
cool if it was like the attack on Paris
when they had to start using taxi cabs
to get people up to the front because
the Schlieffen Plan they just Germans
[__] it up they're supposed to they
were supposed to wrap around Paris come
from behind they could have won the war
like right then but then this dude got
really bold and came down right at Paris
it's uh it's one of the points where we
could have completely lost dang yeah
yeah but just touching back like that
bummed me out a little bit you know as a
huge fan of like 1942 playing as both
sides
um if that's only present in multiplayer
that's kind of it's kind of a bummer to
me because I would like to see that
other perspective especially you know
World War One you there is a different
perspective there more so than World War
II which is always you know as we said
like a higher level sizes as like good
versus evil yeah
um but yeah I mean it more or less it
the trailer was very yeah I mean I I
just I got bits of it and I and I and it
felt pretty cool
it looked pretty cool there were these
these moments of you know a heavy fog in
the forests like that almost remind me
of like I called what was the Call of
Duty Modern Warfare sniper Mission I'll
kill it up yeah all gillied up just like
I don't know I just feel like there's
gonna be these moments of that and I'm
just that made me excited yeah the
Gallipoli Scouts he looked like a
grizzled old dude from what they showed
the one I was thinking of like with a
rifle in the cape I don't know I'm kind
of hoping there are some measure moments
in the campaign not just all out like
charging trenches like you're doing
multiplayer or not just trenches
multiplayer but just charging like
control points and whatnot I'm
interested how they're gonna kind of
trend like transplant the battlefield
formula into a campaign because I in my
opinion they've kind of failed recently
they mentioned yeah and that and how
linear they are more or less and they've
been saying they're gonna do like more
sandbox area areas and make it a more
Battlefield campaign at least that's
what their marketing is saying but I
hope they do to try to translate that
like actual this battlefield you're
playing on into the campaign rather than
just this long line of like follow this
character yes yeah they mentioned a few
scenarios and like their release today
the press release where you know one was
like you know you come across a German
tank you can either destroy it or you
can hot wire it you know and use it
against you know X or vice versa like
storming an artillery encampment you can
turn the guns the other way
um so that was like okay cool that's
exciting yeah because I mean I remember
one of the most frustrating parts of uh
Battlefield 4 or was it three I came for
counting um was when you oh man it's
aircraft carrier scene and you brought
you you and your buddy are pilots and
you're going up to your like F-18 and
you get in the back and you don't even
fly yeah you just Point missiles in
certain directions
I think I literally stopped playing the
campaign yeah because that made me so
upset well that's why like I said like
just to double down what I'm saying I
hope that they find some way to make it
like a Sandbox where you don't have to
be in a plane in this set piece a moment
because that's very like a Call of Duty
thing when I think of I hope they're not
just gonna say you're in a plane for the
entiretiest mission shooting shooting
down like enemy planes and dog fights I
hope they say here's your objective go
capture that with these people and then
there'll be a story thing to like kind
of contextualize this if you want to get
a plane go do it they are pilots so I'm
assuming like it's probably gonna be a
behind me lines moment or something when
they're like down Behind Enemy Lines I
think you see some of that I think it
was the clip where the guy was about to
hit him with like a yeah look like a uh
what do you call it like a um
it looked like one of the guys from the
plane yeah yeah I don't know yeah I
agree with you but I I think there's
gonna be moments of that yeah it's
that's it's not like the campaign's not
like make or break for Battlefield
that's not why I play battlefields but
because it's World War one and it's like
very unexplored games and like uh you
know in literature it's explored but
even in movies it's kind of like not
always there it's not the it's not like
a good versus evil thing like World War
II it's not like a more reason like her
locker or something a lot of people's
lives still relate to we're like past I
think the last person that was fought in
World War one died recently semi
recently in the grand scheme of things
so it's a war that's very much passed
but it still was a very bloody conflict
Like rules exist today in war because of
how bad this was and the world exists
today because of the effects of like new
borders and everything uh so I'm
interested if they're gonna maybe not
take advantage of the terrible term but
like maybe if they can like utilize that
in a meaningful way in the campaign it's
tough man it's wishful thinking I would
say but yeah I guess we'll see the
trailer
is kind of encouraging but at the same
time kind of not encouraging don't let
me bring you down I think it looks good
I just I just want to measure our
excitement it looks like it'll be
exciting it's a good trailer right like
that's what it is it's exactly yeah it's
exciting I'm I mean I'm one of many
people who are playing this just for
multiplayer uh but to have a campaign
that is you know enjoyable
I'm not I'm not expecting like a history
lesson I think we all kind of knew that
coming into this game like from day one
sure uh they said they said like an
interview Alex cronell the producer said
we're not trying to make a documentary
yeah and I hate saying that works
everybody makes fun of me for it but
yeah they're not trying to make a
documentary they're not trying to it's
like it's historical fiction for all
intents and purposes they're going to
use the setting and whatnot to tell
their own story and we'll see how that
story goes I'm pretty sure though
the history books did have a horse with
a flamethrower guy and a minigun guy on
top of it I'm pretty sure I saw one as I
was going into battle Yeah I love that
yeah someone said like uh that the joke
was like
um it's kind of a politically charged
joke but it showed like the GIF and then
someone had said uh oh but putting women
into this game was too unrealistic
because out their quote from like a year
ago when they first released it uh cool
so that's Battlefield one it releases on
PS4 Xbox One PC on October 21st so what
do you think of the new trailer let us
know what you think let us know what you
think about the uh the upcoming campaign
let us know in the comments below Rob
Handler thanks for coming on
we're gonna get Eric Tayon to talk about
Destiny we are he's heated dude he's got
some ammunition already always heated
he's pissed he's pissed about this six I
gave it he's been doing it he's been
like doing a speed bag in the background
to Eye of the Tiger to come on and
debate me about this did you uh did you
play any rise of iron Pete no no no no
no I'd like to remember you tried
playing with the taken King but God
bored no I tried playing I played the
Destiny Beta And then I tried playing
when it actually came out and I got
bored very fast yeah no Eric you've been
playing a lot of Destiny right in the
expansion yes I have I played Destiny
like 10 years ago when I played a
fantasy Star online uh I gotta just say
that all right Destiny rise of iron our
review is up I did a review in progress
on release day uh after you had done a
10 hour live stream I played less of it
that morning but then you know got up my
initial opinions which I think we
aligned more initially yeah
um and then the farther into what we got
the more our opinions diverged uh yeah I
mean I think it's just or I mean I think
we both felt the same way uh everything
leading up to the raid I didn't dispute
the kind of the score that you were like
hovering around at that time which is
ultimately the score you gave it and it
and I could see that like the slog or
the grind of you know you after you get
through most of the story which was good
again but short and after that it's kind
of like this slow process of slowly
leveling in the hopes that you can then
get to the raid
and when you get to the raid which is uh
you know something you did and I did I
thought it was a pretty Great Raid
there's probably like one boss that I
didn't care too much for uh but
it's all a perspective of like how much
does that rate impact you right like is
that enough to elevate it to a seven
yeah not
um and that's kind of where I think our
paths kind of uh forked in the road so
to speak what uh without spoiling too
much what'd you think of like the raid
bosses and the mechanics of the raid
sure I thought it was fun I mean
it was I don't know if it's just because
me and my some of the guys that I read
with normally just haven't rated in a
while but uh the genuine the genuine
excitement of kind of going into it
together for the most part blind I I did
look up some strats and stuff like that
but like actually doing some of those
things like the raid mechanics and
whatnot it was like pretty refreshing
pretty fun it was some of it is tied
into like what you did before the raid
like the strikes and stuff like that but
not all of it like some of those
mechanics lend itself into the raid but
I thought the raid was a lot of fun I
think the mechanics were fun I think
visually some of the set pieces in there
are just like stunning I'm just like wow
that's like blow me away like and I
don't want to get too spoilery with it
but there are some some areas like
within and outside of the inside and
outside of the array that are like
pretty crazy I wish there was a strike
in this expansion that kind of used the
same assets and aesthetic and kind of
general idea of this raid because the
closest they got was uh was the uh
Anarchy Heist I think I'm screwing that
up with the
yeah which was a good strike in my
opinion I like that boss fight just
because it's nothing like spectacular
but it's you know like the ogre's
attacking you you realize pretty quickly
he's immune uh the entire fight so then
you have to kill the arch preach while
this ogre is charging you I like that
boss I like the mechanic that the damn
the dynamic between those two and the
level of design for that one was pretty
like different than most of the other
strikes because it had you glance going
up and down and left and right
um but yeah it would have been kind of
cool to see some of the the more raid
kind of like style in like a strike or
something something that maybe uh in the
previous expansions I feel like they
kind of like LED you towards the raid
yeah yeah it's kind of like oh like
there's you know a specific like one of
the bosses you might fight he runs away
you know you kind of have to go chase
him down and or with uh with servitor
you know you have to move the aura ball
he's like rotating this wall it's all
about placement kind of which rays are
often about like platforming and kind of
being in the right spot at the right
time and like actually not getting wiped
in one hit but uh it was one of the
earlier boss again without spoiling too
much earlier boss in the raid that kind
of you're not just fighting it you're
also kind of using it as like
Transportation almost uh the I mean it's
not gonna spoil to call it that's
Zamboni the death and that's the name of
the boss yeah okay I like this game it's
uh yeah you should have given it a seven
it's Wayne that's your Wayne Gretzky
with a giant battle ax going at the
Zamboni don't clean my rink no okay
there's definitely none of that no not
at all but yeah what do you think of the
strikes because like I said I like the
actual new strike but uh you know
sepik's perfected the one we see right
here is suffix Prime but you know just
like uh what now he's a splicer Siva
they're trying to use Siva um we talk
more about like Siva being that nanobot
plague that the Lords of iron back in
the day with Lord Saladin who you'll see
if you ever done like iron Banner
Crucible Crucible events this all
doesn't make sense it's just like PVP
stuff that happens on a weekly basis or
whatever uh like a scheduled basis they
go into the backstory with that uh we
can talk about the actual storyline
campaign later but you know Siva is this
man about plague that plays into some of
the strikes and it changes the enemies
kind of like how the uh taken enemies
perform differently I didn't feel like
the splicer enemies were that much
different this time around they were
just you know buffed in terms of uh
damage and uh defense yeah I mean I
agree with you for that for the most
part on that in the in that regard that
the taken when they had done the taken
felt like there was more stuff happening
with that than there is with the
splicers
um
so and and to talk about the strikes too
it does kind of suck a little bit that
they were just kind of some rehashes I
mean
it's kind of hard regardless but I mean
I still enjoyed the this epics like
encounter that last encounter even
though it's kind of similar to what it
was before but some of the mechanics at
least were kind of cool it's like you
know you get a Scorch Cannon to then
take a shield off
it's like something that you would see
in like a MMO you know what I mean and
the music during that like fight is just
like amazing I don't think enough people
talk about how amazing the music is even
though that's just one small part of the
game but like that song that that song
is kind of the same as it was before but
like more like kind of metal and whatnot
and it's just like awesome but yeah yeah
the the enemies didn't feel that much
different this time around
um even the play glands the new Patrol
Zone it there was more to do and it was
a different area but it was still very
much just like the Earth from Destiny
year one and two yeah I didn't feel like
I was seeing anything new like the
Dreadnought I loved and taken King it
was very much this like infested kind of
foreign like just derelict vessel in the
middle of Saturn's rings that you were
going into and there's like new public
events that's when they introduced uh
and then there's you know archon Forge
in this one which is kind of like a
reworked Court of oryx in a way like
nine player max nine player public event
I didn't feel like the plague lands were
offering that much new like for me to
explore I was exploring them mostly for
that questline where you're actually
trying to complete all the missions for
uh Shiro the hunter what'd you think of
like the new well yeah I think part of
the reason why the play glance probably
doesn't seem as cool when you go through
it as just like an area is probably
because you're going through a lot of
that through the story I I would imagine
um so you kind of go oh I kind of been
here uh before whereas it wasn't always
the case with like the other expansions
and whatnot so I could see why that felt
that way and there is only one kind of
like new Patrol uh Mission which is a
fun one because you get to use the ax
but I mean like other than that you're
just kind of like killing stuff and
archon Forge is an interesting concept
well not really I guess because it's
like it's it
it's because it's like a watered-down
version of like Court of Works they
wanted something like faster paced that
like it resembled more of like a horde
mode not something that you had to be
super strategic about yeah it was more
of like a lot of stuff's coming at you
like frantically you have a timer of
five minutes you have to kill stuff fast
and that's kind of the concept of that
but I think because it went from like
you doing Court Of Orcs where there were
mechanics of like oh if you don't bring
the two knights together you can't
damage them or
um there's three Wizards if you don't
kill them all within a timely manner
they start to respawn so like there
those probably seemed more interesting
than just killing a bunch of stuff but I
don't know maybe some people like The
Horde style mode so maybe that's why
they went with it our archon sport is
kind of like a and they didn't really do
themselves a big favor because you can't
stack those offerings
um so people can't really chain them if
you don't have them or like if the group
doesn't have them whereas like in court
like you know you could be there with
three people and you can just keep doing
it and keep doing activities but for
whatever reason they kind of like gated
you from like doing them like over and
over we were talking about it earlier
with a division but
um with the update 1.4 it's apparently
gonna like revamp how you level up a
little bit um with like at least from my
experience someone who kind of had to
catch up right before it came out with
my light level it felt very much more
like a very very gradual like very
grindy now with like okay should I
should equip all my even if I don't like
these guns I'm gonna equip my things to
get my highest light so the next thing
that drops well you know ideally be
higher Light Lift my light level and it
was just like constantly playing that
getting in strike playlists and going
through the same you know a few strikes
obviously you know what strikes work
best and what would like drop the like
class specific items and whatnot but it
felt I know that the grind is part of
Destiny I do enjoy it initially but
um after a while this was just too much
almost yeah this this one was definitely
a bit grindier than the ones in the past
but it kind of it's kind of
part of it is because they came out that
April update which was like the infusing
of light kind of stuff which a lot of
people were happy about right and I
think they wanted to carry that forward
so you can still use the old items that
you liked and bring them up to current
light level but I think in doing that
because you know you still have to get
to like raid level they probably had to
find a mechanic to like buffer you from
getting there too fast because if you
get there too fast then like what do you
have left to play right like that's the
thing with Destiny is that yeah you have
your chores and stuff like that but if
you get to end game right away like in a
week which some people have you're not
there's not much left to do outside of
the stuff in the book which again is
still gated like you still can't finish
that stuff unless like you do it so it's
like kind of like extending the life of
it but at the cost of kind of making
players like Ryan through that stuff
like it's kind of an unfortunate
circumstance where
like it's already hard enough to get a
raid group right because that that
mechanic's not necessarily in the game
yet but they have Community sites and
lfg stuff on their site to help
facilitate that but like to get to the
light level to do that which even was
like a little bit of a struggle for you
at first because you know that is a slog
a little bit even though you are getting
rewards it's just minimal like it feels
minimal you know and so it takes time
like that is uh kind of shitty to me
like I want more people to be able to do
the raid but then it's like how do you
find the balance like as a raid person I
feel like an elitist and it's weird for
me that goop shoot right who is a
Gamespot fan is like almost as highlight
level as me and it has like he's done
like only two parts of the raid you know
what I mean whereas in the past it was
like oh you get to the the point where
you're stuck you have to raid and then
you're either hired because of the raid
so then like where's the balance there
right like do you try to it's becoming
more of a casual game I feel like I mean
even if they kept it as extended as it
is right it sounds like if the strikes
are more original and like especially
the the bosses that you were fighting
like that that sort of could have
provided that balance that you're
talking about where it's like okay I'll
take a longer raid if that's what it
takes to keep me playing if initially I
was given things that were super
interesting but it sounded like you had
to go through stuff that was recycled
content to get to something
that was just stretched out needlessly
yeah well even in the strike playlist
you'll be playing to like grind through
the strike playlist keep your stripe on
and she'll be playing strikes from year
one and two because they're put into oh
gotcha yeah well the Nightfall this week
wasn't the new strike right uh the next
last week yeah was the new strike but
then this week uh it was like winter
's run but then they've changed it again
to saber now but yeah so yeah in general
you're it's not just like that
expansions content is re-scandles
contest you're playing old content as
well in order to like
[Music]
um and then in terms of campaign it's
kind of the same thing as taken King it
serves mainly to set up the late game
quest lines or the Exotic quest lines or
the new Quest givers a new area the new
social area uh the new Patrol area which
is the plaguelands in this case uh fell
winter Peak was kind of cool it was just
like aesthetically it's like Game of
Thrones kind of mixed with Lord of the
Rings that high fantasy stuff
um the intro cinematic was gorgeous but
it was one cinematic and then you beat
the campaign in 90 minutes you get the
blade at the end the Exotic item it's
not really a spoiler I think most people
know that by this point but
um it wasn't there wasn't much context
to the missions aside from what the
quest Giver told you at first again like
uh I didn't get into this just to play
the campaign but the campaign like you
know during the marketing everything
before it looked pretty badass and then
I played it was just kind of you know
like lackadaisical I didn't I don't
remember much of it I like the uh I love
the galahorn quest line that last
mission with galahorn was great uh felt
kind of like something out of Bungie's
uh Halo days like the scale of it
um then there's a few I don't know I
didn't get kava stock the original rifle
you get in Destiny but the got a quest
lines as always were pretty entertaining
despite the fact that some of the quests
in those lines were just like fetch
Quest Patrol missions yeah but that's
like part of that's just how that kind
of like how quests work if I mean I
never want to call Destiny and MMO but
like those Patrol missions those kind of
questline kind of stuff like picking up
medallions that are all over like the
playlands that's a very like MMO thing
to do yeah
um it's not really worth giving it a
pass though right I think it's a fair
criticism to say it's like yeah it's
traditional and that's kind of boring
sure but but it but I guess I have a
different perspective on it it's because
it's like yeah I wasn't that thrilled
about having to pick that stuff up but
it's kind of like the you can see the
light at the end of the tunnel and like
it makes it I I don't know if it
necessarily makes it more rewarding to
know that I did all that to get the
galarhorn but you know that you earned
it right and like you know that someone
else that has a Gala horn went through
that same thing
um but yeah and then the cabasa thing
was cool like there's like this
heartfelt moment that if you've been
playing Destiny since like year one like
there's a nice little like like little
nugget of uh
story like intimacy between you and The
Ghost and just like kind of like looking
back at like you know the two years that
you've been playing Destiny and like hey
you know but yeah uh groups you write in
the chat said hey wait I got to access
phase two check your effects Eric hey
yeah all right so that is Rise of iron
uh yeah the reviews up on Gamespot gave
it a 6 out of ten uh it's I think it's
worth playing if you want to grind and
you want to get the new gear obviously
if you're a hardcore Destiny fan The
Raid is well worth it or the raid is
well worth playing The Raid if it's
worth the grind it's up to you
um but yeah that is Destiny um rise of
iron it's out on PS4 Xbox One right now
uh we still have the giveaway right
after uh GameSpot is gonna be tweeting
out photos of
things from pgs that Mary Kish and Alexa
got through customs
Curry like uh Bel seem baby chocolate
Crunch stuff like this you know
geek life King's glaive soundtrack I
believe yeah so stuff like that just
retweet it if you want this stuff maybe
it'll go to you we don't know probably a
lot of people retweeting it hopefully
those individual items they are I
believe I think there's gonna be photo
maybe maybe groups but I think it's just
gonna be individual items that uh you
know like retweet if you want that so
yeah cool that's the giveaway and uh Rob
Handler right after the stream we're
just pretty much gonna pick up with Rob
Handler's uh Forza Horizon 3 stream so
get ready for that I'm ready my body is
ready Pete Brown Eric hey thanks for
coming on what do you guys uh what do
you have going on this weekend
well uh we maybe just got a certain
something in that requires a lot of
attention
uh yeah we got PlayStation VR and cool
so I've gotta spend a lot of time
reviewing the games and experiences for
that before I jet set off to the other
side of the globe yeah Aaron Aaron had
brought up the idea of like Rob coming
onto the set with it on but then he
would have ran into some kind of
expensive equipment which I would have
liked to see that would have been good
for us from a comical standpoint from
like a financial standpoint for the
studio wouldn't have been good and maybe
Rob would have got an injured but that's
not important
keep playing yeah you could keep playing
Dusty uh yeah I am
um probably not as crazily as I have the
last week I'll do my raids and stuff
like that it's it's still like a social
game for me like if you played cod with
your buddies or whatnot you just hop on
and do that so I'll still do that and
then you know whatever live streams we
have going on and you know one of our
good buddies is you know time the knot
so man we know is getting married no I
don't know are we allowed to I don't
know oh okay all right well someone a
former Game Spot yeah a former Game Spot
well if the grind and Destiny's not
satisfying you you got the division
public test servers for uh update 1.4
another game I know you love the grind
in anyway cool so yeah stick around for
the Forza Horizon 3 live stream right
after this as and then keep an eye on
the Gamespot Twitter account maybe you
can win some of those hot TGs items
Alexa and Mary brought back oh and it
looks like one of them is autographed
it is I do not know who that's autograph
I don't recognize the autograph
um we will I'll tell the social team to
mention it in the in the tweet
anyway yeah I will not be here like next
week actually Pete is going to be
hosting I'm going on a trip until
Tuesday so peep around taking over yeah
I'll pronounce it correctly I'll use
classic terms for things in video games
and not latch on to newfounds pick me
anyway thanks so much for joining us and
we will see you next week at 2PM Pacific
as always
documentary
foreign